we're starting off strong i have beef
with you because every single time that
we start a podcast you want to correct
my shot okay what did you hire me to do
okay i'm here to help you produce this
podcast in the best possible highest
caliber ever we're the best we're the
number one boxes
sick and tired of you
getting over to my camera over there and
saying alex no it needs to be two
millimeters to the left but it's not
good okay objectively it's a bad shot so
i have to fix it i disagree with it and
if the few times where we've let you
have full control without doing anything
we look at it and we see him post like
why are we all like yellow
out of context you guys you guys can't
see it because it's always before we hit
record on these podcasts but every
single time we'll have a guest right
there some person we haven't even met
yet usually and alex and graham will be
bickering the entire time about one
camera angle that one specifically no
sometimes it's this one sometimes it's
mostly that yeah mostly mostly though
that's my beef with you right now look i
agree with you it is why we hired you
but then again the most important thing
is just at the end of the day the angles
are set right and if that means that you
guys have to bicker a little bit or
maybe graham has to tweak your angle or
you tweak graham's angle the thing is
you can just start it alex
and he perfects it he puts his spice on
it yeah
he gets 95 of the way that extra five
percent i was like
dude like i gotta move it like that yeah
that's all it is you know what guys
welcome back to the iced coffee hour
okay we're we're happy to have you
thanks for tuning in let me do the intro
better hold on hold on
let's go over there
i want to see your intro that was a joke
that was joke welcome back to the iced
coffee hour we got a very uh interesting
episode today we wanted to hop on and
talk to you guys about some stuff uh
uh number one jack you wanted to bring
this up and i think we should address it
we should address it to do right by our
viewers yes so we had the tech lead on
our podcast this last sunday and it was
met with a lot of criticism so people
were basically saying that we shouldn't
have had him on because he's a
controversial person and due to his
actions like people can't respect him
and therefore they cannot respect us for
bringing him on um and we figured we
should just have an open discussion
about it to do right by our viewers and
not sweep it under the rug and act like
it didn't happen yeah there was a part
there where we posted it and we knew
that tech lead was controversial to
begin with and even when we were talking
about it tech lead even was like yo i'm
controversial uh i don't i don't want to
get you guys in trouble we and we told
them like hey listen as long as you're
okay with us asking you tough questions
i would be okay with it because we could
at least address these these things
you're controversial for a reason can we
talk about those reasons get to the
bottom of it um we wouldn't have had him
on had we not been able to discuss the
you know that caveat yes and he was open
with us he's like you could ask us
anything you want to we could record it
and i think uh i guess number one we
could have been tougher with our
questions yes and it's
it's difficult in person because when
you see someone in person
it's i i guess i i'm nice i'm like
i don't like i try my best
to be like confrontational and like to
put people on the spot but like deep
down
i'm just friendly i don't know like it's
yeah it's it's just tough i'm working on
i'm working but i do think in the future
look here's the thing
we do this podcast for you guys we do it
for the viewers and if you want us to
bring on sometimes people with opposing
viewpoints people that you don't agree
with controversial people um let us know
and we can continue doing that on
occasion one maybe one out of every 15
episodes if you don't want that at all
and just want us to disassociate with
those types of people we will 100 heed
that it's just whatever the group thinks
obviously there will be people saying
yes there will be people saying no but
whatever for a vast majority of you guys
think we will 100 do that because at the
end of the day we do the podcast to
entertain and educate you guys yeah
it is it is tough because there's that
balance between if we have somebody on
we give them exposure is that the right
person to be giving exposure and is you
know even if we present it with you know
a confrontation we ask these questions
are those the right questions to ask um
i think we're still figuring that out
and we're trying our best
but we also acknowledge that we're not
perfect and uh it's a learning process
for us i want to do my best and speak
out more too because there's a lot of
situations first of all i love debating
i i'll sometimes disagree with people
just to debate
like my camera angles
you know but i was right in that case
but you know and uh sometimes i feel
like uh you guys always tell me this off
camera like alex if you have something
to say but in like i never do because
sometimes i feel like you know i'll kind
of stop the flow uh but i feel like i
also have to do a better job of that too
because
um every time that i've
butted heads with somebody i feel like
it's been good so um and who doesn't
like to see like like you guys said a
healthy argument is fantastic yeah who
doesn't like to see opposing viewpoints
and um i think it gives people more to
choose from or more
you know mental food and one thing for
certain if we do bring on a
controversial guest we are usually we
are always aware that they are
controversial we can do it right by you
guys to make sure that we do ask the
hardball questions the actual the and
confront them yeah you know what we
could do would be better
you could add me on instagram now now i
i i going somewhere with this you you
add me on instagram at gpstefan okay
when we are having somebody on the
podcast we could open up the discussion
and have you guys ask the questions i
would love that so that way it's like
hey we're having so-and-so on what do
you want to ask yeah also read off this
question add me on instagram because i
want more followers and more clout yeah
at jls s-e-m-b that brings me to a good
example so thank you guys so much for
watching that's it that's the iced
coffee hour underscore photography i
need a better handle
so uh but yeah great point graham yeah
so that's it we just figured we would
address it to do right by you guys and
not sweep it under the rug and act like
it didn't happen it was a very
challenging podcast for us to film and
uh we hope that you guys appreciate the
transparency and honesty
yeah
now speaking of transparency and honesty
jack yeah you've got a new uh assistant
that you gotta yes your assistant yes
you replaced me no so you know
everything there's more people than i do
i said it's so weird so i currently have
two uh
contractors working for me
he's very specific about that one that's
true they're not there it is true as as
per law like you can look at the
agreement that we have variable you know
anyways that's that's into the week
so i have uh a personal assistant his
name is jj and i recently hired him and
he's been helping me out with a lot of
the house stuff that's been going on a
lot of production for the videos just
random stuff that comes up where i feel
like it takes my mind off of the things
where i should be spending my my energy
productions for what videos
productions for my videos and also
sometimes the iced coffee one video that
you posted in like three months two
videos actually in four months but also
yeah i think that it's great and you
know he gets experience and i get
experience managing someone and it's
been really good he's you know for
example i um you know this but i i have
an airbnb at my house now uh oh yeah
actually maybe should i be saying this
publicly because i don't know if i
should be saying this yeah you should
well i don't know if i want people just
say it all right so i think you always
charge more right i mean that's true
people start booking it you just start
trying yeah
jack honestly you may want to like keep
this sentence
in it but if you charge up the wazoo 500
a nightly why not if someone wants to
pay you 500 a night to come and
hang out you know
bring a tinder date into the pool with
you so yeah though i mean that's it i
have it i i rent out a room on airbnb
it's funny because it's the downstairs
room which actually it had a uh a lock
on the outside so you could lock people
in to the room that's the creepiest
thing yeah jack told me about this i'm
like you gotta remove the law yeah so
why did why did anybody build one of
those locks into a house to begin with
that's a great question i don't have the
answers until they punish their kids i
think it might be because it's actually
it's an actual lock i mean i'll throw up
a photo right now of that lock but it's
it's crazy with a chain and everything
so i had to remove that before i started
you know renting it out on airbnb i've
had three guests stay it's actually very
lucrative i set my price fairly high
what was your price what are you
charging so initially i was charging i
think it was like 75 dollars a night
plus a 15 cleaning fee uh funny cleaning
fees on airbnb's by the way first of all
just from the start
it's just one room by the way yeah it's
one room and to sign up for airbnb is
one of the easiest things i think i've
ever done in my entire life so they have
like an application process but really
all the application process is is you
just submit five photos of your you know
whatever dwelling it is and uh and
that's it they approve you basically
immediately and then you can base you
could literally just have people going
in there and you have a full-fledged
business from there on you also tackle a
cleaning fee on top of the base rate
that you assign per night and the
cleaning fee is shown different
obviously in the listing it's like base
rate plus cleaning fee and then your
service fee and that's like what airbnb
takes but the cleaning fee just
literally gets rolled into your profit
so you can set whatever cleaning fee you
want you could do a 50 per night uh you
know room rental and then you could do a
100 cleaning fee on top of that it's
just like it's just advertising
basically how do they break down that
fee like do they take a certain
percentage of the cleaning fee like can
you make it like an old shipping ebay
trick back in the no i'm sure that the
the yeah the cleaning you keep a hundred
percent of the candy yeah you split that
like ten dollars
that's a great question but i'm sure
it's it's it's probably the same they're
probably wise enough for that but yeah
my cleaning fee is fifteen dollars
are you the one clear jj is that does he
get the 15 so jj i just pay him base per
project uh so he cleans up after the
airbnb but it's been great i've had
three guests so far uh they've all been
really nice
and uh it's profitable it's incredibly
profitable check i'd put it up for like
300 a night what if i rented out my
office
can i rent out a couch is it can i put
that on airbnb i think so yeah probably
i think
so you need
to select what type of residence or
dwelling it is and
like i think the smallest you can go is
like a private room in a residence but
you might be able to do a couch
maybe well technically i could have that
be a private room
i just go in there but then i can't get
work done yeah you know but it's been
great it's incredibly profitable so if
you have a house and you have an extra
room airbnb is a fantastic way to not
have people staying in there 24 7. you
could select four or five nights a month
if you just want a little bit of side
income the application process is
incredibly easy and it's very easy oh
one other thing jack i want to ask you
you were talking a while ago about
walking a hundred or was it it was 300
miles you wanted 300 miles las vegas to
los angeles yeah it was at los angeles
las vegas 300 miles
and i talked you down from that
100 miles and you did it and i did it
but yeah i had not posted a video about
it the issue was that it's seven hours
of raw footage and also it's raw footage
of a video that i've never edited
anything like this before because it's
like an in real life type thing where
you have to like use all of these
generators and all this stuff and i also
hired out an editor because i realized
it's honestly it's beyond me like i
could edit it but i
i just it would take so much time that's
it i mean the walk was it was probably
one of the hardest things i've ever done
physically it was definitely the hardest
thing i've ever done uh my feet were
completely blistered i'm still not
completely healed from that like on my
heels there's still skin like peeling
off and that was two months ago
yes certainly yeah it was worth it i
would edit the video yourself because
you know the exciting points to hire an
editor to go through seven hours of
footage and pick what they think is
exciting i would know the thing is
though i got him to chop it down from
seven hours to like 40 minutes and then
from there i'm gonna have a lot more
control i just wanted the daunting task
of looking at a seven hour timeline and
then bringing that down to like 40 45
minutes and i told him to be very
conservative with what he cuts out and
then from there i'm very hands-on hey do
this edit right here do this edit right
here this is what i wanted to look like
and he just gets it done i think what
would make you a better videographer
would be for you to edit it because i'm
not a videographer you're filming
youtube videos you're from being a
videographer
you're a videographer to a degree
because here's the thing when i first
shot weddings i came home with like so
many images
and i learned that i was overshooting if
you took the time to go through that
edit yourself and you learn okay why did
i film that that was kind of pointless
this was good then you would learn
what not to waste your time on
i've edited plenty of youtube videos
i've edited yourself said that you've
never edited something like this that's
true and i did try to edit it but every
single time i was just overwhelmed by a
seven hour timeline and i'm like you
know what so you guys quit every time it
gets a little hard jack come on dude i
walked for six days 100 miles seven
hours yeah you walked 100 miles man you
can handle that it was also really
challenging looking through those seven
hours of like something that i it was
six days of my time you know what i mean
and like re-watching all that like
remembering all the feeling that i had
and like the the stress and the i don't
know how hard it was it was difficult as
well what'd you do today jack i'm
curious me today yeah what'd you do okay
uh minute by minute jack yeah like what
time you wake up i woke up so late today
i woke up today probably 9 30. okay i
got up late and then i had coffee i
played probably three games of ping pong
with my housemate and then i went
upstairs and i
uh
i edited uh i started editing my next
video
and then also after that uh i had a call
with someone that lasted probably 30 or
so minutes about our tick tock strategy
because we're now posting tick tocks of
the iced coffee hour and also i had a
meeting with my accountant after that i
worked out after that i played a little
bit more ping pong after that
and
uh i think i'd i probably spent like 20
or 15 minutes thinking about different
topics for this podcast
um
so we got an hour we got under an hour
work done for like the business itself
yeah i would say but i still have stuff
to do later tonight because i have to
review the episode that's going up
tomorrow for the graham stuffing show
okay two hours yeah
oh so i reviewed a script for for the
iced coffee hour sponsor okay yeah two
and a half
yeah so what's your what's your problem
with that
just uh i'm curious what would happen if
you if you gave four hours
you know four hours during the week how
how much how much we can improve
channel iced coffee hour but it's the
one thing you've you've never done this
and i keep asking send oh you know what
you did steve the steep will do at house
tour you sent me this evil that was i
thought it was a good idea that was it
that was a good video the problem is
graham pass these two the reason why
it's been hard for me to stay motivated
to be completely honest and transparent
and something i've been realizing lately
is because
i'm at a point right now where since i
have hired stuff out it's very easy to
just maintain and any work that i do on
top of what i'm doing right now it's
extremely like diminished utility like
there's honestly it wouldn't do a lot
it's like yeah maybe i'll pick out a few
other second channel videos to do maybe
like like the sponsors are already
completely filled out i have someone
that writes the scripts i check the
scripts we film the scripts we get those
up we have a podcast episode i make sure
of that i have a huge list of people
that we have to reach out to or that we
did reach out to there's honestly
there's not much more i have to review
second channel videos after they get
that takes a little bit but i think it
frees up your mind to think of bigger
ideas now i agree because you've got the
everything else taken care of what's the
next step i agree bigger ideas and i
think the bigger idea is we need to put
shorts on this channel i think the tick
tocks are but that's exactly what i did
today
that's exactly what i did today
so it's like we have not posted a short
on this channel though yeah i know but
that's also because i'm waiting for a
really good one to be posted on um
the tick tock which actually got posted
today if you no yesterday if you haven't
noticed a million views oh we need to
post more of those i know that's that's
why that was another michael reeves once
we have in the pipeline uh i told him
that i want a lot more yeah so that was
when i told him five to six i agree to
think that i'm just taking it like you
know like i think it's a lot of ping
pong
i
all i'm trying to say is that's a lot of
ping pong yeah it's a better ping pong
than wasting my time away on tick tock
or watching like pointless youtube
videos okay and youtube videos could be
great because it gives you ideas for
other videos to react to like patrick cc
that's not going to get me i wouldn't
want i would click that
that's why i said pointless you know why
would you even click the one videos that
i've been clicking on is bad is the uh
the car accidents videos oh no the car
accidents compilations and it's one of
those things where i clicked on one just
out of
morbid curiosity and they're not like
you know gruesome car accidents or
anything it's like the ones where you
like see a car and there's you know
you're just like the guy's not paying
attention and like you know the stuff
like that they're doing stupid stuff
it's nothing gruesome but anyway you
click on one of those and just
constantly get them recommended they're
like eight minutes long and it's just
those are the time wasters i get nothing
from this i also feel like you don't
need to
uh
i'm not in the same mindset as graham
like that that you need to work 24 7.
i'm not saying that you shouldn't add
more work
but i i think that you're a different
you have a different approach to life
i i agree to a certain extent it's like
there were periods of time in my life
where my life was work for example when
i was living in santa monica and i
didn't really hang out with people
they were but the thing is things are
completely different now than they were
in santa monica in santa monica like
like i said i was structuring out every
single podcast i was editing every
single second
here too yeah so it's like to compare
those times to now where it's like yeah
things are cash flowing like they're
successful businesses now and for to
expect me to continue like like like
it's not like my actionable like things
i can do will actually
make as much of an impact as they could
in santa monica and i think that
demotivates me so i'm trying to find
something where i can like go all in on
and here's the thing it doesn't make me
happy to to be
feel like i'm not necessarily needed in
these things because i've built up these
systems to automate them like jj like
andrew who who edits for me it's like it
it doesn't make me happy knowing that at
the end of the day i look back and i'm
like well what did i do i reviewed a
video oh i filmed some scripts with with
alex and made this amount of money it's
not that great i don't like it
why did you stop the vlog
i just got tired of it it got boring you
have to be honest uh no i don't think i
got boring i just i got sick of filming
it i got sick of having to be like
here's my one day off my one afternoon
oh we gotta film the vlog and force
ourselves to do something that's why i
got no no but you originally were like
no we don't have to do anything special
it could just be whatever i'm doing that
day and then through and for an entire
month they did three a week with
whatever i was doing that day and he did
so well
that's because it was new
if you don't have anything different the
videos did just as well the videos were
doing just as well
three weeks into doing three videos a
week
i think it was getting very repetitive i
but the views say otherwise i mean the
views were just as good
chuck what do you think
i wasn't as interested in those videos i
do think that there were more views
because it was new and i think that
people liked just the consistency in
their schedule that they know that they
can tune in three times a week to
something where they just put it on in
the background and you know listen to it
um but i i was much more excited for the
vlogs when there was more stuff going on
and when we actually went out of our way
to do something for the vlog i think
that those were better vlogs and i i
stopped watching graham stefan after
hours when you were doing three times a
week i just wouldn't watch it it's funny
i felt the opposite i felt i hated the
vlogs and we were doing stuff like i i
thought it was fun to go to the grand
canyon and do this stuff i hated filming
it i just like it took me out of the
moment to be like oh i gotta be on
camera it's just could not
i do feel that too because i i mean
obviously i was on on camera too but
yeah guys what could i do better be
honest please
i think
like your your perspective when it comes
to like giving us your opinion on
something sometimes i'm worried that you
try to tell us what we want to hear
and when you go against us you do it to
show that you can go against us
i disagree with that go ahead
uh no i agree with jack in the first
part i don't know quite what you meant
about showing us that you can go against
i thought the speaking up thing is a is
a good one that's that's a good
suggestion
um
alex you've gotten a lot better at being
uh
time efficient
the editing to the last few videos that
alex has edited
i would say are almost perfect i mean i
was as perfect as you could get them
showing it to me like obviously we watch
it and we're like oh we could cut this
out
otherwise the video is perfect
um
so i can't i can't
get you on editing because the editing
is you got that down
uh well let's let's address jack's point
i guess real quick i don't understand
what you mean because i'm very
outspoken about my opinion and with
everything so i'm surprised that you
think that because if i truly don't like
something
i i'm very honest about regardless of
who cares i'm surprised that you think
that it's just something i don't know
sometimes like i have experiences in the
past where like we'll show you something
and then you'll
go again you'll you'll go against it
immediately because you want to
provide some sort of like contrarian
perspective but then
maybe graham and i will actually think
that it's like very good and we'll like
reason with you and then like a flip of
a switch you're like oh you know
actually it's good so
that's it you know like
maybe that isn't the case but for me i
remember in the beginning it was a
little challenging for me to honestly
provide graham with some honest feedback
sometimes because you know i really
respected graham and i didn't want him
to think poorly of me but it was really
just through the growth of like being
friends with graham that made it a lot
easier i agree becoming friends with
graham makes it a lot easier to
communicate it's so weird because if you
like if i envision myself having
conversations with you
six months ago versus now it's like so
different yeah alex talks back to me
sometimes but sometimes it's funny yeah
it's funny sometimes it's fun
sometimes alice i don't have time for
that that's what that's when i get like
first of all that's not time that's not
talking back that's me being honest with
you there were some times where i i
think there's one time where i knew you
were editing a millennial money podcast
and our agreement was like you could do
the millennial podcast as long as it
doesn't interfere with the main channel
everything else because that's like
that's the priority and when i asked
alex to get to like i checked and like
can you get this done but also the same
quality for the main channel the next
day and i said i don't know if i have
time for that i'm like i'd rather you
not tell me just do it because because
you do have time you'll find time there
is time and he's like well i'd rather
just be honest with you i'm like no you
don't have to be honest yeah i was
trying to i was trying to be transparent
yeah i'm like no it's bad and you know
what it turns out i banged it out and i
came in and grabbed fine that was good
it was a good video i was like thanks a
mindset i'm like don't there's there's
you don't tell me that just mentally you
could think how am i going to get this
you'll be fine yeah i will agree with uh
with that point where i do have a really
weird mindset and i think
uh i've been trying to kind of
you know think a little bit differently
um just because i think sometimes i can
be hesitant about things
and i think that sometimes you pushing
me like that helps so i'll keep pushing
grams gram's good at pushing i will say
that's one of his strengths as a boss
he's very good at pushing you
but one thing just to just to
really you know take it home
uh is that i think that for you graham
you need to outsource you are wasting so
much time and losing so much money doing
the things that you do and for you to
tell me
that what i've done now to put myself in
a position of having to work as few
hours as i do is a bad thing i would i
could not disagree more i think it's a
fantastic thing and although it is
difficult like i said for me when i'm
lying when i'm lying in bed like
thinking what did i do today and i'm
bummed out because i didn't do a lot
it's like i still now
have
like i want to do a lot more and i know
that like this free time that i have
spurs a lot of creativity which i think
is really important at this point it's
not about
the actions that you do but it's about
the decisions and choices that you make
it doesn't have anything to do with your
actions i hear a lot of buzz words jack
alex romozy moses that's that's alex
from rosie it's not about those little
tasks that you do it's about the
decisions that you make when you're
heading this big of a business and still
for you to be spending as much time as
you do on the things that you're
spending your time on it's a complete
waste of time and i think you're losing
a lot of money i don't know i take pride
in those things like doing the
thumbnails so are you doing it for pride
or are you doing it because you think
it's a smart financial or business thing
to do both do it for pride and also
i i think the thumbnails the planning
obviously no one can replace me filming
so i think those things i have a
competitive edge because i'm in it so
much and because it's my thing and it's
my creation and it's like from what i've
seen
being immersed in it i think it you
can't replicate that to the same degree
yes you can you can do it better you
don't want to replicate it you can do it
way better why don't you take over the
uh thumbnail for the podcast
because it's the exact same thing every
single time oh and i don't even have the
background
okay you don't have the background well
also i do all the other stuff on the
podcast so it makes sense that you you
handle the podcast
why don't you do channel thumbnail then
podcast because i do with other things
let me talk to you guys let me talk to
you guys through a dilemma i'm having
maybe you guys can give me some guidance
here
um
so for the last i had a conversation
with graham maybe two months ago and i
was like graham
what can i focus on
and he said alex you just gotta get the
edits down
and i took that to heart even though it
took like two or three conversations
with graham i'm not gonna lie
but i think i finally like i'm at a
place where i'm like
okay like i'm harnessing i got got it
down but now i'm looking at what i'm
doing
and
i feel like there's no scalability in
what i'm doing
what do you think is that for me or jack
both of you probably ask jack because
we've talked about this so often yeah i
agree i mean editing three main channel
videos
there's no scalability and i told graham
when i first did this i was like i don't
mind doing this for for a while you know
it could be year could be two years
could be whatever
but i don't see a scalability on this
and now i'm thinking to myself
well what do i do
i think and and i don't know if i'm
going straight here you guys yeah i
wanted your honest advice as
you know friends and as as business
people
i could focus my
hours that outside of editing because i
i can't outsource my editing
graham doesn't like it and you can't it
doesn't make sense no why
don't give them ideas no if i were you i
would find someone else that can do an
even better job no i would tell graham
you'd have to no and not telegram until
no that's the thing i would find someone
that can do the exact same edits at a
cheaper price you oversee that you take
the spread
can just hire them directly it's not
getting watered down it's the same
product it's the same exact final result
someone could even do it better than
alex and that's the thing you were not a
believer you said that you should be
editing your main channel videos for the
until the end of time and then you hired
alex and it was hard i remember it was
hard when you were training alex but now
think about the time that you have it's
taken
it's taken six months to get alex to the
point where he could edit a full video
or where there's no real revision but
that's also due to your particular
person yes i know but particularly slide
i'm not gonna let anything but now is it
worth it
yes i would say this i sometimes don't
find myself any more productive
is there anything wrong with that
i'm spending more time planning but it's
also more challenging
your plans
it's hard to say because there's less
going on in the market so i need to be
i i need to put double the effort
planning videos when there's nothing
going on a year ago this was easy when
every day there was a new event new
event new event yeah but you have a you
have a bigger roi on
your time spent planning versus time
spent editing
true so i think it was a great decision
and you didn't believe it at first and i
was telling you over and over benefits
sometimes is that when i do plan i zone
out
it's like that is because because now
there's no zone out time flies like that
yeah yeah i can't i can't like finish
filming and be like all right back to
planning there's that like three hour
space where sometimes when i would edit
your mind just goes away and you kind of
get in that creative zone and
bang out a video and then afterwards
you're like ah yeah but there's always a
solution to every problem there's a
solution and you can find some some
other way to spend that time
yeah no like i'm not even joking like
i'm i'm using it as a metaphor like the
reef tank i have tinker with her if you
wanted to you can spend that time doing
something else
you found a solution to that problem a
new a new problem came up but you can
find solution that and it will only get
better it's hard because what i'm doing
is working so well
it's working i mean when you look
objectively
it worked so what if it works well if
you want with your logic with what i'm
doing it can always work better right
and i'm using your own logic that used
it on me
guys let's circle back around
back to me yeah you know
so now i'm looking at the time outside
of editing what do you want to do alex
you tell us so no so that's what so
that's what i'm i'm looking at and i
don't want to spread myself i feel like
um maybe a month ago i was i had all
these ideas but i feel like if i do too
much i'm going to spread myself too thin
so i don't want to because i was like
well i could scale if i start shooting
weddings again and stuff and i do all
this stuff i could i could do that and i
could scale that but then i'm like yeah
but then you know i'm gonna have to edit
during the week uh which is fine
um i just want more control over it so
i'm like
what can i do outside of my editing time
that is actually scalable because let's
be honest the the stuff that i'm doing
for grab i cannot scale that income i
can do other things for you to scale the
income i would agree with that
uh but what do you guys think my time is
the best spent doing i could make uh
you know i i told graham i wanted to
make it like a photography course he was
kind of iffy on that
i could do i could do more content that
i like to make for myself i mean i could
i could do my wedding business and uh
not run not do the actual events myself
i could outsource that but it sounds
like the question you should be asking
yourself because you talked about
youtube it's like are you it's not like
you were doing that that's more of a
passion exactly so do you want to
allocate your extra time towards a
passion or do you want to allocate it
towards something where you can scale
your income
that's the thing it's like
exactly so i think you have to yeah alex
no you can't use both you could
start up the reef tank and make reef
content so easy to do
film for like 30 minutes i'm not gonna
lie yeah after i found out okay so guys
i'm getting a reef tank breaking news
okay gambling money with gambling money
i went out yeah i went out and i gambled
with graham and jack they lost their
money
technically i lost half of my money with
them and then on the way out to the car
i just couldn't help myself i was
itching i'm just kidding
no i i decided to do the irresponsible
thing i don't condone gambling
irresponsibly and i put down money and i
turned it basically within two days i
turned it into about thirteen hundred
dollars to
so
uh
so uh instead of going and re-gambling
that money
i'm going to take it and i'm getting a
reef aquarium yep i'd get the reef tank
vlog it and so i love reef reef content
people don't know but i grew up with a
reef aquarium in my living room it was
like andrew's our friend andrew it was
just in our living room it was huge and
my parents hated it but me and my
brother loved it so
the thing that baffles me is the fact
that you just consistently win that
gambling i know i
how much have you made in profit because
you have it you have a spreadsheet yes i
have a spreadsheet
my net profit including these gambling
winnings is 3 900 wow
39 in one year i would just quit i mean
wait if the irs is watching i mean um
i lost thirty nine dollars i would just
yeah i'd quit while you're ahead spend
that towards the reef tank there's the
next like a year yeah cause do you guys
remember the first uh few months i was
here i was basically living rent-free
yeah because
and you're playing blackjack no i'm
playing blackjack
it's not it's not a game of skill
because you don't know how to connect no
it's all purely luck like in the long
term if i continue playing statistically
i will lose money that's right and so
quitting while i'm ahead getting the
reef tank you know
putting it in my house honestly if it
were me i would never gamble again
for the rest of your life put it towards
three tank have a great time vlog it
yeah well what about okay so you gave me
a good idea of her passion vlog my reef
tank vlog segment vlog the learning
process or you know the learning process
document that
but what about the scalability of my
income what would how much you told me
in the very beginning you just want to
make 60 or 70 grand granted he's like
that's all i need to do no that's not
what i said what do you say that's not
what i said 80 grand no yeah you
you don't recall what i said no i said
honestly i was like
i'm not sure exactly how much i want to
make but off the top of my head i said
um i've seen a lot of research that like
the threshold for diminishing returns is
like a hundred grand no it's not it's
70. yeah it's like 75. you told me that
all you wanted to yeah like a certain
amount and anything over that you're
like i'm just happy with that yeah that
was like 90 grand yeah exactly no it was
not 90 grand yeah it was less it was
less than that no it was not
i guarantee you guys
wait wait wait wait okay okay let's cut
back into the
oh wait we can finish this if you want
but that regardless of of of that right
i still want to build something that's
scalable
alex you no because
you we even talked about this on the
alex for a mosey podcast you wanted a
certain amount of money you said after
that that's all i want and that and that
would make me happy you've hit that
amount
let's not confuse that i am happy yes i
am not but you've reached that point
with a schedule now that is extremely
flexible where you've got it down you
want to get this to muscle memory where
it's just like you don't even have to
think yeah you're doing it it's done but
you've you've hit that amount
so now the question becomes how much
more money do you want to make is it
about the money or is it about doing
something that you enjoy you know i
think at this point i got to do
something you enjoy i think that's a
great i guess that's great to make 20
grand more and you'll be like how can i
make money you know what i think that's
a great perspective coming from
yeah i was like wait wait coming from
honestly no but you you the phrasing was
right because doing something you enjoy
i know so many different opportunities
to make more money and i think at the
end of the day it's just
what do you want to do
pick that what opportunities have you
given me the second channel when i was
just like alex twice a week it's gonna
take two to three times a week vlogging
the clips channel you gotta post you
cannot click your channel you cannot uh
you cannot hold me back for for the vlog
thing because
i've told you about going specific
directions trying things i was so
restricted robert ducky's in the pool
dude try it try it no i'm not doing it
i'm not gonna do it but you never let me
have like a freedom of that like we have
between the thumbnails between some of
the things that we've done there's a lot
i would say no
i would say no i mean like i added my
own style to it but at the end of the
day i
the stuff that we were doing
trivia
the thing is
you're you guys are arguing on different
planes you're talking about creativeness
and you're talking about uh money so
like
yeah your creativity best product we
could yeah i know but your creativity
was stunted on the podcast for sure
because graham would you mean
yeah sorry the vlog yeah but you could
still made way more money had you found
sponsors for every single episode and
stuff like that so
look i think what i said still holds
true is that you just need to figure out
do you want to spend your time doing a
passion or do you want to spend it
trying to find something where you can
increase your income yeah so that's
right and there's no
there's nothing wrong with wanting to
make more money i want to make sure i
agree there's nothing and we're not
accusing you of saying oh you know it
doesn't matter
but you have to figure out for yourself
more money or passion me
pick the passion do the reef tank with
the vlog
once a week on the block i don't think i
wouldn't spend more than three hours on
a vlog
yeah honestly three hours a week reef
take content
pursue the passion i think that i
i didn't realize i was at a point where
i think i'm in a position where
i think a lot of people don't
ever get and that's to be able to do
something that they're passionate about
and i feel like maybe i've been taking
that for granted yes enjoy it yeah
does that make sense it does yeah yeah
that was a good talk no i appreciate
that so exciting news we got a new
intern here harvey you want to come on
in i'm all the way from london
thank you alex all the way up
thank you guys
everything everything you say is sounds
just very fancy yeah you sound smart man
i don't really have it to me it doesn't
seem like i have an accent but does it
sound like we have accents to you strong
yeah we are very very we have a very
strong very strong very strong what if
we talk in your accent
so to me do you to you does that mean do
you think i have a really strong accent
yeah very strong but it sounds good it
sounds like your voice booms man people
always say american people think english
accents are like something crazy and
it's crazy yeah
anyway welcome so how about this
tell the viewers a little bit about
yourself just it's a background my name
is harvey heggs i'm 17. i'm the new an
upcoming finance youtuber
um but graham's giving me an opportunity
and i'm here on the podcast you
literally best podcast in the world yeah
you flew uh 10 11 hours to fly down here
yeah for three days now here's how crazy
it is you sent me a cameo request yes
that's right seven months ago six months
ago just saying hey i want you to appear
on my channel for like five minutes for
an interview and i i don't know if i
even responded to you and i think you
messaged again i don't think i responded
and then i think i said like hey sorry
i'm not not interested like i appreciate
the uh the consistency because you kept
responding you just kept on me kept on
me like would send like might be a view
jack and that's and that's like some of
it that
actually i wonder if i could pull it up
here
yeah you could see
all the messages
i think it was like 20 26 at the
beginning to send you yes
yeah you did a cameo 4.99
um no actually no no because i turned on
free messages and then you turn them
free messages because because i didn't
want you to because i knew it was a no
and i was like i didn't want you to pay
for this but anyway uh july 31st august
17th september 7th october 25th october
29th november 4th november 5th november
25th december 27th you just kept going
kept going and then after a while i'm
like you would not quit
and i'm like well we got to give him
something to do so i'm like to talk to
jack
just give this give it to you something
like if you want to do something just
get to have jack
give you something to do yeah uh but you
just we're so persistent
and i forget what it was but eventually
i i called you i think you just like i
just wanna call or something like that
and see what else i could do it's like
okay fine
called you you're so enthusiastic and i
was like jack you just give him some
more to do but anyway you would you
would not quit you would not go away and
so after a while i'm like oh and then
this is where you started getting
persistent about like i just want to
come i got like spring break coming up
uh for a week i just want to work i'll
do anything you need to i just want to
work and i was like oh yeah i don't know
we're going to have the time and
honestly i didn't know when we're going
to have the time it's so last minute and
you got like an 11 hour flight yeah and
uh you were so persistent you're like
how's monday i was like jack how's
monday alex monday okay
all right fine fine and uh but but the
persistence yeah why were you that
persistent
well to take it all back to the
beginning i think um
i've always been like and then finance
has never really been my i've never even
thought about finance it was always like
any bit of money i had designer clothes
and then once it was like i had a bit of
money from school for passing my exams
and it was either this like lacoste bag
or and then a video popped up of yours
never seen it i think you're on like a
million subscribers at the time watch
the video and it just like because i've
always been interested in money i've
done like the typical we used to sit on
the front and do sales of things in the
fridge and stuff like that um so money's
always been a thing but the money i've
got i've just spent i've never really
invested that was never really a thing
for me i came across your video
and it just just triggered something for
me as i've done a bit more research and
then i was just like i've just got a
message this guy i started my own
youtube thing as a little passion
project
and i was just like
the main guy in the space and see if i
can interview him and just
see what it's about just really went
headfirst in the whole thing
do you ever feel embarrassed though like
sending multiple messages like
back-to-back yes when i send it i'm like
jump back like oh
but i just i know how busy you are like
how many times you've said you get
millions of emails messages so if i send
one
and leave it it would
as you probably know jack you'll never
get through and you'll just skip over it
oh it's another one of them so i just
keep
my name kept coming up just reminding
you
until jack then give me a bit of work
hopefully done that right and then a bit
more bit more bit more and then here we
are now and it wasn't only that but also
you were commenting on every video and
that was already my way yeah because we
see
the first hour and you're like graham i
sent you a message let me know you got
it in the comments yeah
but
yeah
that was
it seems embarrassing but
i'm here now with probably the best
opportunity i'll ever get in my life
just goes to show you guys make sure you
comment and like comment on every video
dgb antho is also very similar and and
dgb has been a tremendous help i i know
you're watching this so i want to thank
you for everything uh but dgb didn't
even ask for work he was just like
commenting on every single video and he
got so good with algorithms that he
would uh without
he would know when a video is not
performing well and he would just
automatically comment
i think this title is better i think
this thumbnail is better he got so good
at it that he was better than jack and i
estimating how well the video is gonna
he guessed today's video
what
i don't know he's better than us no no
here's a surprise he guessed what the
vid today's video was ranking in the
first like three minutes and he was
right
in three minutes i can't even tell how
it's gonna get through but he did it
three minutes
like it blows my mind and so uh so i
brought him on also as like an intern
yeah so basically um you know i just i
give him a little bit every week just uh
just for his help and he moderates the
comments like she's so good but it just
goes to show you it's like sometimes
that persistence it's just you stand out
it's just finding a way to stand out in
a way that uh that it just catches
someone's attention they they're able to
see that
um
why didn't you work for mark tilbury
yeah uh it's a good question
the english finance youtuber um i think
at the time when i was saying uh the
story
that
without like
trying to suck up to you or anything it
was like that emotional connection you
know when something so big changes in
your mind i'm not even just saying this
every money i had was spent elsewhere so
that change was almost like connected to
you
um
mark toby wasn't even like he had he has
had like that massive
growth spurt in like a year didn't he
just
went off and at the time mark toby
wasn't even like
i think it was on like 100 subs maybe
100 000 subs so you was the main guy in
the space
um
and obviously you've said mentioned
loads of times before you started off
the finance in that way and that's
probably when i first found your videos
so looking back at it now it's probably
been over the last three or four months
when mark toby's been big
um but i just had my
sights set on this
darn it i don't know
why why stop now all right and we just
met like an hour ago by the way so that
that's how like fresh all of this is
what has been your first impression
like everything alex picking you up from
the airport coming up here
crazy dust storm yeah so england weather
is awful by the way minuses um we have
probably one month so getting off the
plane that gust of heat and
sand in your eyes obviously it's the
desert i was like oh god man um but yeah
on the phone to alex sorting out where
to pick me over at the wrong place
um and then straight here and straight
on a podcast with
probably my 22nd hour of the day
wow yeah i know and we're about to get
sushi it's it's my treat tonight thank
you um thanks thanks grab yeah we're
gonna go to super sushi
in las vegas they've been hooking it up
lately super sushi las vegas it's uh
they're great we used to go there like
twice a week yeah and then it got to a
point where like wait we're eating too
much sushi so harvey what kind of value
do you think you can uh contribute to
this entire business yeah so on the way
here that was
i'm not i wouldn't say i'm ever going to
be able to
specialize in one
say i'll say i'm coming here as an
editor i'm coming here but what as you
can see persistence um i've tried
anything i've always been up for
anything
and playing sports and things like that
being able to
any task you give me if you teach me the
basics and what to do
give me like two weeks a week and i'll
start nailing it and get better and
better and better there's never
something that i'll probably sit and
think i can't do this i'm just going to
give up
see what i'm saying the more i do
something the more happy just have to
show me the basics and then
hopefully build from there so you're
down for anything it's funny because i
was with my housemates before i came out
of this podcast and i was telling them
about you because you're you're staying
two nights with me and they said why are
you doing this i mean he's from you know
a different country why why is he coming
out here and i said well you know graham
orchestrated a decent amount but also
for me from messaging me right now
a good reason for me why i i'm totally
fine with it is i i honestly see a
decent amount of myself and you because
i didn't have any skills going into this
job like there was nothing from that
moment that i could have provided
motivated that's all
that's it graham could give me any task
and i had no regard for my time i didn't
care about it i'm like yeah sure give me
a 20 hour task to do in like you know 28
hours and i'll just do it i don't care
so that's kind of something that i see
in you and uh i respect it you know the
best thing in this industry is if you're
trying to if you're trying to get into
it and you find a mentor it doesn't
matter how much skills you have it
doesn't matter if you're proficient in
final cut pro premiere unless if they're
looking for an editor of course but
there are so many ways that you can
provide value just by giving someone
your time you know what i mean and
that's what i tell a lot of people that
are trying to get into somewhat similar
positions at me that's what i've said
yeah sorry just that's what i've always
said to you i've just said give me the
boring the worst the longest stuff take
that time off your hands because
obviously i see the benefit
that frees up your time and then what
you can do
coming in with a business mindset as you
say free up more time for graham and
every bigger things can come from that
just by getting little things you're
going to get a little bit of all of us
here because you'll see you'll kind of
mentor
excuse you jack on work ethic yeah in
2022 now uh you could watch jack
uh you'll watch alex and see what he
does and then in between that we could
go over things because like we're
planning if it's me just sitting in
front of me it's not as good but like
comments thumbnails reviewing videos
like stuff like that we could do
together
um and there'll be some like you know we
could we don't you'll help alex on the
podcast room and stuff like that but i
think it'll be a good experience you're
saying to jack about watching youtube
videos and
is a simple task for me to do watch
videos send them over to you
yeah oh good yeah yeah see second
channel videos yeah harvey i'm
delegating that to you i will be
outsourcing that and not taking no no
yeah yeah
so videos that you think will do well
from an algorithm standpoint second yeah
hopefully just question
question things and yeah a few questions
yeah give a different
opinion that's fantastic
so
what do you think about graham
like i know meeting him in person was
probably a lot different than what you
thought of you know over the internet
did he exceed your expectations or did
he go eat or below yeah is he like way
below expectations
above i've got to say that good okay
good wow but obviously you only see what
online it's like it's so hard um
but obviously just by messaging me back
and give me this opportunity how can i
ever say a bad word
in general just because the opportunity
gave me messaging me back giving me the
time obviously so busy
um
[Music]
but yeah well honestly had you not
followed up because you were like i want
to fly down on a flight yeah give me a
week give me a week give me a week give
me a week and eve in all the times where
i'm like i don't know i don't know these
dates are i'm out of town like just let
me fly down let me fly down let me do
that
over and over again
and then when you're like monday
yeah okay monday it is it worked yeah i
just thought yeah
just keep saying it yeah put a date in
your mind instead of
you coming to me all right and just see
what goes from there and so here we are
so you're here for three days four days
what do you want to get from what's the
one thing that you really want to um so
i do a bit of my own stuff so obviously
asking questions
from you all of you would be so
beneficial to me more than
money could ever pay for just so that's
obviously something beneficial to me and
hopefully i can show
what i can do and
if you see something in me and then
hopefully
goes from there just set a good first
impression really cool in the time we
have looking forward to it well i think
we're good it should be a lot of fun go
off to super sushi you got to be
exhausted and first task black card
go and talk to the owner let's see if we
can make that happen
thank you guys so much for watching this
has been a great midweek episode i know
it's our second one we've ever done just
let us know what you guys think people
seem to like the first one so let us
know if we should keep it up yeah if you
like it let us know in the comments
section
you could also let us know which stock
you gave when you uh sign up for public
using the gram public.com and let us
know which stock you get
uh we'll link to all the information in
the description so anyway thank you
thank you guys thanks for having me
thank you alex and until next time
thanks man yeah